this world is tough man and it's even
tougher when you're alone dude and i
tell you you know there's no doubt in my
mind
i would be
i would have been in jail without my
father
even though we don't have a great
relationship with no doubt in my mind
but i would have been able to deal with
my father if not for my mother
that i would not have been able to deal
with him if not for her running
interference and if not for him i would
have been in bad bad shape
was was a crazy wild child
you know if you think i hate authority
now you should let me let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question so
who would you have done better with if
it was just your dad or just your mom
wouldn't it work either way i would have
broken my mom if my dad wasn't there i
might i would have broken her
my i would not have
done the right things early enough i
wouldn't have matured early enough not
to have broken her heart if my father
wasn't there and if my mother wasn't
there
it would have been an unsustainable
situation between me and my father would
have it would have come to a head and
one of us would have had to go
and and
oddly enough
they raised three kids they raised my
sisters are incredibly incredibly
intelligent successful people very like
you know allison is a marketing
executive emily's an assistant dean like
they are incredibly successful
you know very very brilliant woman
and my parents probably
and i don't realize this until i'm an
adult
they didn't have a great relationship
they sacrificed
30 40 years of their life
probably being with the person that they
shouldn't have been with
specifically because they decided like
like the cfo decided that yeah there
they made their life about you guys they
made their life about us they never
missed a single game they we didn't take
vacations our vacations were baseball
trips to you know the regionals to
soccer on the weekends they they never
they worked their asses off my mom
worked two jobs my dad worked 60 hours a
week no vacations
our vacations were soccer tournaments
yeah you know what i'm saying and i i
gotta tell you
if
you could give my father a truth serum
right now dutiful irish man well never
he said look this is what a man does
i bet he regrets it
i bet you he thinks that that he should
have made more time for himself and his
dreams and his passions along that way i
feel like he gave up
too much of himself i feel like my mom
gave up too much of herself they made it
too much about us and they these are
incredible parents are you saying they
made the right choice
i don't i think the lesson here is some
sort of moderation that i i i don't
think they could have done any better
and especially me i did not make it easy
on them i wish i would have made it way
easier on them right
but they did as well as they could and
on a grand scheme in a grand scale they
raised a pro athlete and two incredible
incredible you know these successful
females right
but there's a reason me and my sisters
aren't married
this was a this was a tough relationship
we saw a lot of fighting well there's
still hope for you buddy you're 35 years
old you'll do okay look i understand but
but it's there's a reason
and there's a reason why this generation
is not getting married there's a reason
why people are living longer
i think that there's a lot more options
out there you've seen divorce i saw what
divorce did to my uncle i saw my uncle
go go to work i saw my uncle my
godfather god rest his soul
work
60 hours a week
living on his sister's couch while
another man lived in his house with his
ex-wife that man refused to marry my
aunt because as soon as they got married
my uncle would be off the hook on
alimony yep so
seven years this man
my uncle essentially financed another
man
being in his house with his wife
so why would you want to be married you
know what i'm saying so listen i got a
number for a therapist for you dude
we're gonna have you call it we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna set you up all
jokes aside therapy save my freaking
water so if anybody out there that's not
a joke i cannot advocate for therapy as
much as possible so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]